a trip to barcelona wouldn't be complete
without a visit to la rambla
the soul of the city all year round
millions of tourists come to soak up its
irresistible charm
at the heart of the boulevard is the
world famous market hall
la bocaria welcome to la bocaria
market it's one of the best markets in
barcelona
the market is steeped in history dating
back to the 13th century
this is one of the many stalls selling
fruit vegetables fresh fish and of
course tapas
one of the oldest and most famous tapas
bars is pinocchio
owned by juan baien
you'll need luck on your side if you
want to get a seat here though most
people leave it up to juan to choose
their meal
he's an expert in traditional catalan
cuisine
my mother opened this business here in
la bocaria long ago
she passed the tradition on to me and i
managed the shop now with my son
we've had many opportunities to move but
la bocaria on la rambla
is my home
grew up here he's witnessed many changes
to the street over the years
but for him la rambla will always be the
place to see
and be seen
no matter where you're from in barcelona
everyone gathers on la rambla
and that makes it one of the most
beautiful places in the city
la rambla is around 1.3 kilometers long
and runs from the hustle and bustle of
plaza de catalunya all the way to the
port of barcelona
a statue of columbus stands at one end
the rest of the boulevard is split into
five
sections each with its own name that's
why it's often referred to as
las ramblas in the plural
juan bayern's favorite is la rambla
saint george's
also known as rambla de las flores for
the many flower stalls
this spot on la rambla is where people
were allowed to sell flowers for the
first time in catalonia
and this tradition lives on today in
these stalls
they represent a wonderful piece of
history
it's said la rambla was once a sandy
riverbed
for more than 400 years a wall separated
barcelona from the western district of
al raval
in the early 18th century the wall was
torn down and the tree-lined promenade
was built
the first flower stalls appeared in the
mid-19th century
and soon became a local landmark
as did the grand theatre del desail
which opened in 1847
the opera house was destroyed in a fire
around 20 years ago
it's now been repaired to its former
beauty
the history of the boulevard is also
reflected in the numerous street cafes
although most people here are now
tourists they stroll down the street
year round
unfortunately making it a gold mine for
pickpockets
but they also provide an audience for
the many street performers
i like the fact that it's green and open
and nice but it's very very busy
i think the street is beautiful it
reminds me of the chancellisse in paris
it's very authentic especially the small
market behind it
la bocaria it's fantastic
but for locals too la rambla is still
the showplace of important events
at the faun de caneletes thousands of
barcelona fc fans gather regularly to
celebrate their team success
this fountain is also one of juan baen's
favorite spots
the water has more to it than meets the
eye
this water is magic legend has it
that if you drink from the fountain
you'll stay in barcelona
forever
staying here forever with la rambla at
your feet sounds appealing
even after all these years the boulevard
has lost
none of its charm